[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors même de très bonnes ya quatre ans
je m'éloigne tu t'éloignes quoi il me
manque mais accessoires normalement
j'étais supposé avoir des assistants où
sont ils
je vais je vais clair je vais te la clé
des mains j'ai cédé chenal qui attendent
et je crois qu'ils sont intérieurs je
dois tout faire c'est en vous remerciant
barils à rejeter
c'était des quoi fabriquer mais vrai
suspense mois annoncé à l'épée messieurs
le magistrat lors ce jour c'est toujours
on est d'accord qui a rien dans le sac
et dans le public il ya quelque chose ou
pas évident
oui les dividendes alors je me suis
mettre des gouttes gens n'y vont
vraiment on est d'accord que quand on
est à vous si en règle générale si bien
de ramener des fleurs non assurés
moindre des choses dont maxime
[Applaudissements]
c'est super montrer mon talent des morts
à bombay vraiment l'intérieur la même
écoute je sais pas je me dis quand même
temps ne ramène pas juste un petit truc
de fleurs ça fait un peu crevé et chipé
[Applaudissements]
mais à ce qu'il y ait encore quelque
chose à part amener juste deux petites
questions sur ces questions est ce que
ça lui était gêné je ne comprends pas
parce qu'un rien à l'intérieur il ya
plein de choses qui sortent et on est
d'accord que j'ai fait sortir quand même
autant de fleurs du sac
jusque là je les gars vous le montrer
comme un chroniqueur sac est strictement
villes ont ce que vous êtes un peu notre
mary poppins aujourd'hui ouais c'est
vrai c'est pas lesquels mater
l'exclusion sans le plusieurs sont à
tort comme une vue avec 10 h à dieu de
le plus innocent
agathe gérard garima jeudi le dos de la
main c'est pas chez maria mais la main
elle sait faire
jean michel thoury oui et ce climat
malsain autour était super mais je vois
pas trop l'intérêt d'arriver chez les
gens avec une merde pareille
[Applaudissements]
intéressé par ça fait toujours plaisir
avec ces d'inventeurs a ramené de ses
spectacles
on est d'accord je t'avais cacher sa
majesté tablettes et les fleurs sera pas
possible non
et ça va
m
toutes les 15 minutes
[Applaudissements]